c'est un cliché de le dire - recouvrent 70% de notre planète,
dont 95% sont inexplorés.
Notre expédition a pour but de construire
et de démontrer la valeur d'un submersible
pouvant atteindre les profondeurs de la planète
afin d'explorer les 60% de cette planète toujours inexplorés.
DB : Et il vous faut un outil assez cool pour ça ?
VV : En effet.
L'outil est le sous-marin le Limiting Factor :
un vaisseau très perfectionné,
assisté par un navire de soutien, le Pressure Drop.
Sa sphère en titane de 90 mm d'épaisseur, pour 2 personnes,
maintient l'atmosphère constante
et peut plonger à plusieurs reprises
jusqu'au point le plus profond de l'océan.
DB : Comme un SpaceX des océans ?
VV : Oui, c'est une sorte de SpaceX des océans,
mais je pilote mes propres engins.
(Rires)
DB : Vous comptez emmener Elon ?
VV : Oui, je pourrais emmener quelqu'un.
Elon, si tu nous écoutes,
je t'emmène faire un tour si tu m'emmènes dans le tien.
(Rires)
DB : Alors, c'est comment en-dessous ?
On parle d'un endroit où la pression est aussi forte
qu'une Tour Eiffel sur un doigt de pied.
VV : Oh plus que ça.
Environ 1,1 kilobar.
Notre sphère en titane
nous permet de plonger à des profondeurs extrêmes
et de remonter de multiples fois.
C'est une grande première.
Le Challenger Deep a plongé deux fois,
en 1960 et en 2012 avec James Cameron.
Ils ont fait un aller-retour dans un vaisseau expérimental.
Notre submersible commercialisable est le premier
à pouvoir plonger et remonter des milliers de fois, avec 2 personnes
dont un scientifique.
Nous sommes très fiers qu'avec nous
le Dr Alan Jamieson, de l'université de Newcastle
a battu le record de plongée pour un citoyen britannique
dans la fosse de Java il y a 3 semaines.
DB : J'ai l'impression que vous n'avez peur de rien.
VV : La plongée, c'est particulier.
Si vous êtes claustrophobe, n'allez pas dans un sous-marin.
La distance est longue
et les missions durent 8 à 9 heures dans un espace confiné.
C'est très différent de ma carrière précédente,
l'alpinisme, avec ses grands espaces,
le vent, le froid.
Là, c'est l'inverse. C'est bien plus technique.
Il faut être précis avec les instruments
et savoir intervenir en cas de problème.
Mais s'il y a un gros problème avec le sous-marin,
on ne s'en rendra pas compte.
(Rires)
DB : Vous avez peur des fuites alors ?
VV : Les fuites, ce n'est pas bon. Si on s'aperçoit d'une fuite,
ce n'est pas trop grave, Et si c'est grave,
on ne s'en rendra pas compte.
Un feu dans la capsule ne serait pas bon non plus.
Mais notre submersible est très sûr.
Je fais confiance à très peu de choses dans la vie,
mais je me fie au titane, aux maths
et à l'analyse par éléments finis,
qui servent à déterminer
si de tels objets peuvent endurer
ces conditions et pressions extrêmes.
DB : Et cette sphère a été parfaitement élaborée, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est une réalisation remarquable.
VV : C'était le plus compliqué,
construire une sphère en titane
avec une précision de 0,1%.
Le titane est dur à travailler
et beaucoup ont du mal à s'en servir,
mais nous sommes chanceux.
Notre équipe formidable a construit une sphère quasi-parfaite,
la forme géométrique la plus apte
à résister à la pression.
Quand la trappe d'accès se referme sur moi,
je suis confiant que je plongerai et referai surface.
DB : Et c'est ce que vous vérifiez bien ?
Que la trappe est fermée ?
VV : Il y a seulement deux règles à suivre.
Règle n°1 : Bien fermer la trappe.
Règle n°2 : Retourner à la règle n°1.
DB : L'océan Atlantique, c'est fait.
L'océan Austral, c'est fait.
VV : Personne n'avait exploré l'océan Austral.
Je sais pourquoi.
Il est très, très hostile.
Le temps est abominable.
Le mot « collision » me vient à l'esprit.
Mais on l'a fait, oui.
Content que ce soit fini. DB : Oui.
VV: Merci.
(Applaudissements)
DB : Vous ne perdez pas de temps.
Et maintenant l'océan Indien, comme l'a dit Kelly.
VV : Oui, il y a trois semaines.
Nous avons eu le privilège de résoudre le mystère.
Si on m'avait demandé il y a trois semaines :
« Quel y est le point le plus profond ? »,
personne ne le savait.
Il y avait deux candidats,
à l'ouest de l'Australie et dans la fosse de Java.
On a un navire fantastique avec un très bon sonar.
On les a cartographiés.
On a déployé des atterrisseurs pour vérifier.
Le point est au centre de la fosse de Java.
Personne ne pensait qu'il serait là.
D'ailleurs, après chaque plongée majeure,
on s'empresse de corriger Wikipédia,
car ils ont tout faux.
(Rires)
DB : Vous passez plus de temps à descendre
que de temps dans les profondeurs ?
VV : Non, on passe beaucoup de temps dans le fond.
J'ai une réserve d'oxygène de quatre jours dans le vaisseau.
Si je reste au fond quatre jours,
c'est qu'il y a eu un problème, je n'en aurai plus besoin.
Il faut trois heures pour atteindre le point le plus profond.
On y passe ensuite trois ou quatre heures,
et trois heures pour remonter.
Ce n'est pas bon d'y rester plus de 10 ou 11 heures.
On y est à l'étroit.
DB : Ok : donc le fond de l'océan Indien.
Quelque chose que vous seul avez vu.
VV : Voici les images d'un de nos atterrisseurs.
En bas à droite, vous pouvez voir une donzelle,
c'est son vrai nom.
(Rires)
Et à gauche, une créature jamais vue auparavant.
C'est un animal gélatineux à queue de la famille des ascidies,
à l'aspect très différent du reste de la famille.
Elle a un petit alevin accroché au bout de sa queue
et nage gracieusement devant la caméra.
Durant chacune de nos plongées,
bien que nous n'y soyons restés que quelques heures,
nous avons découvert trois ou quatre espèces,
car ces endroits ont été isolés pendant des milliards d'années
et aucun humain ne s'y était aventuré pour filmer ou récolter des échantillons.
Donc pour nous, c'est extraordinaire.
(Applaudissements)
Ce que nous espérons,
notre objectif principal, c'est de créer un outil,
qui ouvrira une porte,
car avec cet outil,
on pourra en construire d'autres,
emmener des milliers de scientifiques en plongée
et ouvrir cette nouvelle porte d'exploration
pour découvrir des choses dont on ne connaissait pas l'existence.
DB : Plus de personnes sont allées dans l'espace que dans le fond de l'océan ?
Vous êtes un des trois.
Vous allez faire augmenter ce nombre.
VV : Oui. Trois personnes ont atteint le fond de l'océan Pacifique.
Le USS Trieste en 1960, avec deux hommes à bord.
James Cameron en 2012 avec son Deep Sea Challenger.
Merci James, super sous-marin !
Nous sommes la troisième génération.
Dans deux semaines, nous n'allons pas juste plonger,
nous allons plonger de multiples fois,
ce qui n'a jamais été fait.
Si nous réussissons, notre technologie sera éprouvée
et la porte s'ouvrira mais surtout restera ouverte.
(Applaudissements)
DB : Bravo. Bonne chance.
VV : Merci beaucoup. DB : Merci.
VV : Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)